what are we doing here
surprise Sunday I can't tell you that
what have you got us into Dave this can
be fun oh my god bungee jump it's
adventurous and fun and we can just
cross it off our bucket
I hope so
I didn't lose you yesterday and
yesterday was my first day so wait you
for one day
geez he's playing with you all of a
sudden you're like hmm I don't know if
this should be my bucket lists anymore
maybe it needs to move further to the
bottom yep you promised me if I'm doing
it you're doing you job a job
there's a piece of dental floss a string
between me and the pavement I mean even
though I am an adrenaline junkie doesn't
mean that I don't get nervous that
before I'm about to do what I'm about to
do my heart's beating like a foam
butcher fit dryer baby I'm telling you
just fall back not on me you're good you
got this when I close my eyes just knock
me on such a thing I'm sorry baby you
got this you've done a lot crazier
things this is about living okay okay
okay
you got a baby it'll be over in a second
I think I've blacked out
I don't remember anything except being
pushed to my death you didn't die though
you're here soon yeah do you feel like
it was a good surprise Sunday I mean it
was definitely a surprise and it was on
Sunday it was the surprise Sunday you
were freaking out I have never been so
scared in my life